Okay, so today I think the market could
looking at a big daily chart here. I
think it looks like we're in a pretty
bull flag that we could get a pop here.
So looking at a 15-minute chart, I think
that looks pretty reasonable. We're at
this uptrend or or this resistance level
with this uptrend into it. you know, we
keep making these stabs and selling off
and so it's likely that we're eventually
just going to break it um and could get
some momentum up. You know, I don't
think we're going to have a crazy move
like this, but we could have, you know,
definitely um a decent move, something
that's worth, you know, on a day trade,
a nice trade in a in a good way. Um so,
ideally though, you know, for me,
we're we're knocking against this. I'm
not going to go long right at this
level. Ideally, we get some kind of like
on a one minute here or a five minute
here. We get a a pullback retest this
and then push higher. I because why I
would like that is it would essentially
be faking shorts to the downside. You
know, it could be a move like this for
just a little while. Get people short
thinking that okay, we're at this
resistance level. we're gonna sell off
and instead, you know, it it does a
little fake and then rips up. And so
that's what I would really like to see
in the NASDAQ and the ES today. Uh
looking at other couple markets here,
oil still just oil just has sucked over
this last month. So just because it's
just choppy and back and forth, there's
no good structure. For a little while it
was in kind of a nice little range that
was a little more tradable, but recently
it's just been an up uptrend slop and
then a big sell-off out of nowhere. So
just avoiding that for now. Gold is kind
of in an uptrend, too, without any good
resistance levels.
Close, but it looks like potentially
it's blown the top off this uptrend
here. When I see that, that to me is an
indicator that the trend that it's
currently in is over. And so that means
either it could go into a more parabolic
uptrend or it could start to go sideways
or it could start to go down. It's
essentially showing that hey, the shift
is
changing here. It's, you know, out of
its norm of of butdding up into this,
you know, trend line here. And so that's
something to pay attention to. But
again, like for me, I don't really see
much in terms of
levels to trade off of there. And that's
what I really like to go off of. And so,
if anything, I'd like to see a
confirmation of maybe it comes up here
and sells off. Uh or if it if it looks
if it comes up here and looks really
good, maybe I'll take a quick short just
to capture a quick little pull back
down.
Other than that though, um I think
there's minor news today at
8 o'clock as kind of usual with the
markets, you know, 30 minutes after the
open. So, just kind of going to wait at
see market opens up in 10 minutes. So,
just going to see how things play out
and see if we can get some movement and
the market sets up how I want and I can
take a trade. And if it doesn't, you
know, I'll move on to the next day. In a
in a market where it's just
hard and choppy and not good trading,
you want to have a setup that you're
looking for. And if it does that, you
execute. And if it doesn't, you just
move on. Otherwise, you're just going to
lose money.
Okay, being patient here. I think it's
going to keep going down. This seems
like a lot of momentum, but we're in a
spot. I would like to take a long if
it's going to set up. you know, my bias
was or my big picture thought was to the
long side. Now, this is a crazy looking
failed breakout with a big sell-off.
But you know what? The market has just
been fakey lately and back and forth.
And so, I think that almost makes it
more likely
that it's going to reverse higher. And
so, I'm just going to keep watching both
of these. I almost think has the ES sold
off more.
Yeah, it definitely has.
So, I'm seeing how it reacts to 30
minutes, you know, that timing window of
30 minutes after the open at 8:00 for
me.
If it breaks this, it it's starting to
slow down here. It's had this big move
down. It's This is almost like a slow
big candlestick attempt to keep going
lower and then we got some more chop
here and it's attempting to go higher
right now.
Okay. So, in terms of getting long here,
I want to see how both these are acting.
And
I want to wait for I think one more
quick pullback, but then I think
potentially long is in order.
And I'm not going to do big size.
Market's been really tricky lately. It's
already kind of had a swing today. you
know, it's kind of already given the
swing back. And I would I really like
would prefer to go large size of, you
know, risking like $2,000 on a trade on
a short just cuz those really work a lot
better. So, I'm just kind of letting
this play out, seeing how it
breaks up here. It's making a new high.
I want to see how it pulls back. I'd
like to see it pull back and then get
long.
ES is pretty much the same.
Again, we're we're pretty much right at
these support levels.
So, I want to I want to be getting long
here.
My hope is that it doesn't
just rock it up without me.
It totally could.
you know, there could have been an entry
sooner, but you know, I'm again, I'm I'm
airing on the side of caution in this
tricky market. I'd rather be cautious
and miss maybe one or two trades here
when trading has just been really tricky
cuz this but you know right now is that
decision point of well is it fake to go
higher and now it's just going to
continue puking lower or is it failing
to go lower and it's going to go higher.
So just waiting on that. Seeing how this
candlestick develops.
Okay. Crazy spike.
I don't want to get in right on that. I
want to see how it pulls back.
But I think if it moves up and then
pulls down
and repushes, I'm going to get in long.
So I'm going to get in long essentially
at a break of this. Be great if it has
just a little bit of a pullback. So, I'm
not gaining in just on crazy momentum.
Okay.
I mean, long moving this up
and seeing what we can do here. I
honestly I would uh just going 2x would
be great just to get some kind of win
since I really haven't taken that many
trades
recently.
Um,
I keep hot keying this on
but you know again big picture like I'm
liking this and I think that the
strength is to the upside.
ES looks pretty much the same too, but
NASDAQ was clearly the better choice as
it's kind of bounced back a little bit
soon more.
Um,
yeah, I just kind of got to let this
play out now. I think ideally I go for
2x, take off maybe half at 2x,
um,
and then
let the rest kind of ride.
We'll see what the market kind of brings
though because remember big picture
if I'm looking at uh here we go the 15
minute chart
kind of hard with some of the drawings
but I mean I'm trying to look to see if
this bare bull flag can kind of continue
higher. Now, we had that little breakout
in the morning,
but if over the day it kind of it just
trends higher, it'd be awesome to have a
couple of contracts
for that.
So, it's playing around here and part of
me wants to go break even, but I'm not
going to go break even yet because I
think big picture, I think this is a
good spot. And I think it's there's
total potential for it to come down
here, have a pullback, and then continue
higher. I don't think that
it's likely to have just a parabolic one
directional move that's easy to hold on
to. Um, I want to give it that wiggle
room to have a pullback, you know, cuz
yes, here this could be the uptrend it
has. Um, if I draw this uptrend, it
could be something like this. But again,
like I think big picture it, you know,
that's what I want to play off of and I
need to give it that that wiggle room,
right?
Okay. So that's kind of the pullback I'm
looking for.
Um, so and that's so so that's exactly
why I don't go to break even because if
you look at where my break even line
would be, holy moly, I would be ticked
off if I got knocked out right there.
I'm going to adjust this uptrend line
because I think that's pretty dang
close.
Um, and then I'm honestly I'm probably
going to
move my stop up to here
just because if it comes up here and
sells off,
I think again, you know, this market's
just kind of choppy.
It's not a good easy favorable market.
You know, I think it's likely to I've
given it kind of that wiggle room.
And so, you know, I want to give it
wiggle room, but I don't want to give it
too much, right? To just make a loss out
of nowhere.
Um, and so I'm going to move my stop up
here.
I may see how it has how this pullback
here works.
Just to see if it makes one more stab
lower and then moves
My one thought is if it wants to just
come and like retest this spike up that
it had.
But I'm I'm going to I'm going to leave
my stop here. You know, I'm really
feeling some indecision about leaving it
here or moving it back down to here.
But that's plenty of wiggle room to give
it. You know, I otherwise you could
perpetually just move your stop forever.
You know, my goal is to let it spike
this once kind of like it is here and
see if it breaks up higher.
Okay, this is one thing I wanted to see.
I wanted to see the ES break this low as
a confirmation that it's the ES is kind
of bearish, too. But it's funny on a
five minute this still, you know, a five
minute this still looks solid. you know,
we could just be putting in a a higher
low on a five minute. So,
it's hard, but you know, that's that's
how choppy markets are. They're really
hard to trade.
It's just, you know, there there's so
many whatifs or, oh, it could just pull
back here and then go higher because the
moves take a lot longer. That's why I do
like to give it some more wiggle room,
but also get out when it does do the
move you're looking for. Um, and it, you
know, it started that, but I think I
would have needed to get up here before
I would have started ratcheting up the
trade. Otherwise, just going for one to
one just isn't really worth the risk.
Uh, even at a smaller size. So, I think
this is just going to continue lower and
break. But, you know, anything's
possible with the market. You never
know.
The ES is bouncing in a nice spot.
We're just going into
a chopfest now. I mean, hopefully, you
know, this is a nice break and so
there's definitely potential to keep
going higher here. I think at this
point, I'm going to move my stop up
below this low. If we break this high,
I'm going to move to break even. Might
as well take risk off the table. No need
to do that in a not do that in a crazy
choppy market. I think also I'll move
my sell stop down
to take off
a lot of the trade at 2x if it does get
up there.
Yeah, I'm going to move up to break even
at this point.
No point in losing money on this trade
now if it decides to
move down.
And I think if we just get up to
somewhere up here, I'm going to I'm
going to
really think about getting out
cuz there's, you know, we're most likely
based on this is we're going to move up
and just chop. But I would like to leave
until we get up to that area. I'd like
to leave my limit order at 2x. I think
I'm just going to have both at 2x. I'm
not even going to mess around.
Oh,
that's what I'm talking about.
Come on, just a bit more, please. Sorry,
I'm having having breakfast. I'm
starving.
Um,
I would really love this to hit 2x. I
would really love it to hit 2x here.
I want to be patient,
but as well like
it feels so likely that it just
I'm not good at just getting out on
spikes like that.
I would like to see I think one more
like print one more candle up here and
then I'll move I'll just pull my stop up
to 1x, you know, essentially retest this
high.
Well, it's essentially retesting this
high, too. Like we in a way you could
say we have a minor support here or
yeah, support now was resistance.
And so be awesome to see it hold that
and then continue higher. And you know,
I I feel antsy of wanting to close this
out cuz it's actually at a nice amount
of profit. It feels impossible to make
money in this market. So anytime you get
a little, it just feels like you want to
hold on to it.
Okay. So, I'm going to move this up to
the low here, the low of this c that
this candle, and then we're just going
to see how this plays out.
I'm just going to let this chug higher.
Honestly, if it if it just wants to
continue chugging higher.
I kind of want to just do a trailing h
it's so hard. Like, part of me is like,
oh, since we have some momentum here, do
I just do a trailing stop?
But from what I'm seeing, it's the smart
move is just to get out at 2x,
call it a day, be happy with 2x
cuz it's so likely that this is just
going to pull back here and reverse.
We're at these highs.
I'm just going to post this to the my
room
what I'm doing. Um, and so yeah, it's
really close to me wanting to pull this
up higher. I think I'll pull this up
just to the previous candlestick. This
one.
See how this next one develops.
ES is looking the same. You know, big
picture, I do think this is going to
move up
more. I mean, I think it's a really good
big picture play.
But with just how the market is acting,
it's getting close actually to 9:00,
which is another reversal timing where I
kind of find that the market likes to
slow down. So that kind of timing with
this level, it's kind of worth just to
get out.
So I'm just going to leave things where
they are and trail up my stop loss and
whichever knocks me out knocks me out.
starting to slow down here. I think if
it gets anywhere like up here, I'm just
going to like trail this pretty
aggressively
because again, it's just kind of getting
close
to my limit. And I'm not really moving
my limit up.
So close here.
So close. It looks like it's going to
just pop up and get it. Come on.
Moving up below this candle. Come on.
Come on. Come on.
Nice.
There we go. Sick.
Done deal.